the third episode of the book of boba
fett really pushed two ideas that boba
fett is supposed to be absolutely
terrifying and that he's basically the
godfather welcome back to streaming the
galaxy i'm rocket riley and the book of
boba fett episode 3 the streets of
mosespa was just released on disney plus
and it was jam-packed full of action and
intense storytelling now let's dive into
a complete breakdown and review of the
episode looking at all the easter eggs
and references you may have missed as
well as the parallels between boba fett
and the godfather don vito corleone the
episode starts us off with a bit of
exposition where the ex-torture droid
explains that most espo was split into
three crime factions after the sail
barge disaster calling back to the
events of return of the jedi where boba
fett ended up in the sarlacc pit the
three crime factions seem quite similar
to the rivaling crime families that you
may see in mobster movies such as the
godfather or goodfellas this
presentation is interrupted however by a
visit from a water merchant upset about
some street youths who keep stealing his
water this interaction is very similar
to scenes in mobster movies where people
come to request things from the dawn
mostly in the form of protection so boba
fett goes into the streets of mo cesar
and finds the ing who had been stealing
from the water merchant and he finds
they're only stealing because there's no
work to be found the gang is made up of
humans who have body enhancements from
droids very similar to something you may
see in cyberpunk 2077 or elita battle
angel boba then hires them to join his
crime family and goes back to the palace
in his back to tank boba has yet another
flashback to his time with the tuscan
raiders and he travels to mosul to meet
with the pike syndicate which we saw in
the first couple episodes of the series
as well as in the animated star wars
series he passes by someone placing
stormtrooper helmets on spikes a scene
we first saw in the mandalorian we also
see a woman with three pet droids who is
most certainly pele motto the mechanic
who we also first met in the mandalorian
these two references undoubtedly point
to the idea that the book of boba fett
is basically a season two and a half for
the mandalorian after meeting with the
pikes who tell him they can't pay
tribute because they already paid it to
the swoop gang bubba returns to his home
with the tuscans but finds it destroyed
with every member of his new family dead
this calls back to the scene where luke
returned to his home to find his aunt
and uncle dead and everything destroyed
as well the scenes that follow are
highly emotional since we've come to a
greater appreciation for the tuscans and
their culture as the mandalorian and the
book of boba fett have portrayed these
individuals in a completely different
light similar to how the building of the
gaffy stick mirrors jedi building their
lightsabers the funeral pyre the tuscans
were placed on in their deaths mirrors
the funeral pyres jedi were placed upon
at their deaths this just points to the
idea that there are likely even more
similarities between tuscan culture and
jedi mysticism boba is then ripped out
of his flashback as black crysanton
pulls him out of his back to tank and
throws him across the room this fight
scene is one of the coolest we've seen
so far since we finally get to see
exactly what a wookie is capable of in
combat the only time we've seen
something close to this is in the final
scenes on kessel and solo a star wars
story when chewie helped the prisoners
escape we also get to see some of the
new crime family members bodily
enhancements with one even using an
electric whip although they aren't able
to overpower chrysanthemum they do trap
him in the pit below the throne room
later the hutt twins arrive to apologize
with a gift for boba fett a rancor which
is lying beside danny trejo who is now
officially a part of the star wars
universe this rancor could be moochie
the young rancor we met in the bad batch
the huts then explained that they're
leaving tatooine and that boba should
too since most vespa has been promised
to another crime cindy kit likely
meaning the pikes although they could
mean crimson dawn which is currently
being led by kira who we saw in solo a
star wars story the twins explained that
war is bad for business which job of the
hutt frequently said before his death
and then they leave tatooine danny
trejo's character later explains to boba
the lighter side of rancors saying the
witches of dathomir used to ride them
these witches were seen in the clone
wars television series as well as in the
video game jedi fallen order it's
explained that rancors are quite calm
and less provoked and that they imprint
upon the first person they see since
boba says that he wants to learn how to
write it similar to how he wrote a giant
creature in the star wars holiday
special in which he first appeared boba
is the first person the rancor sees
starting their bond which will surely
grow over time boba and phoenix shand
head to the mayor's palace which leads
to a speeder chase this chase scene is
very reminiscent of scenes from american
graffiti which showcased similarly
bright-colored car scenes and which was
also directed by george lucas at one
point one of the speeders actually
crashes through an oil painting of jabba
which is a bit silly and the scene ends
with the mayor's major domo crashing
sideways into a cart full of fruit
calling back to when biff crashed into a
truck full of fertilizer in back to the
future the major domo then confesses
that the mayor is working with the pike
syndicate the pikes arrive on tatooine
fenix says that they're going to war and
boba says that they will be ready it'll
be very interesting to see how this war
plays out since it'll likely be very
similar to crime family wars we've seen
in mobster movies the outcome of this
war will likely depend heavily upon who
the city's leaders and rich elites
support whether it be boba fett or the
pykes overall this episode was great
although there were a few scenes which
seemed a bit unnecessary the scene where
boba bonded with the rancor and the
black crystal fight scene were
phenomenal i really can't wait to see
where the series takes us and if you're
interested to see where the upcoming
obi-wan kenobi series will take us check
out this video also don't forget to
subscribe like this video and thanks for
watching
[Music]
you